hello I'm Ezra Miller and I'm going to
give you five of my style icons and
heroes from anno domini the common era
of human existence number one I began
with Simon Bar Kokhba and I'm thinking
of the Arthur zyk painting wonderful
Arthur's dick painting he's got this
beautiful flowing crimson robe he's sort
of wearing a hat like a Roman
Legionnaire which i think is cool he's
like appropriating the style of his
enemy maybe he's got the shield which is
gold with the Star of David on it was
just super dank and then he's uh he's
got the green saddle and reins on his
horse so it's like green crimson silver
in his helmet and parts of his armor and
gold perfect this is a moment bar
kokhba's serving a look let's
acknowledge and appreciate it
number two moving forward in time Oscar
Wilde
[Music]
the poet and playwright who said great
things like you can never be overdressed
or over educated I agree with that
that's the wild was persecuted for being
too gay and too fabulous all the time we
praise and remember you in your
beautiful I feel like I'm almost that
this Santa ROM piece is almost saluting
Oscar Wilde the big fur collar I
remember this one picture was got that
tilted hat which I just always thought
was amazing
number three moving forward into the
Common Era or into the last century
Buster Keaton
[Music]
you know they say fashion what selves
are fashion in the face that's what
someone told me of the saying in Korea
Buster Keaton was the hardcore Pelican a
deadpan dive he would just do the you
know which can really sell anyone the
general one of the greatest movies of
all time lots of books served up I love
Buster teens game calling out what did I
keep trying to get more Buster Keaton
hat game into the the credence looks
they usually end up getting cut out of
the film often with the note that they
look too cool so there you have it at
either number two or number four
depending on how time and numbers work
Jessica Rabbit my childhood very
important movie for me was Who Framed
Roger Rabbit
massive influence in my life my mother
always said in this world people either
want to [ __ ] you kill you or be and with
Jessica Rabbit I wanted to have sex with
Jessica Rabbit and also to embalming
Jessica Rabbit she can't help it she's
just drawn that way strong that way one
of the most devastating moments of my
life was the moment when my sister
revealed to me that you couldn't be a
cartoon character as a profession that
cartoon characters were drawn and that
actors only did their voices devastating
for me I'm still not convinced we'll see
what we can do when I look around I try
to you know look for an icon amongst my
contemporaries I have to go with Rihanna
and thinking of [ __ ] better have my
money the video I'm thinking of the
leather hat look I'm thinking of the
bandanna look in that video we bow to
you
Rihanna we bow to you Jessica Rabbit we
thank you for what you have given us we
thank you for for this guidance I thank
you for this guidance in my life how to
express and be Who I am based on the way
that you have channeled the gods
to God everything nothing the beginning
[Music]
[Music]